the holiday special  i can't be more excited for this if you  don't mind me asking  is what can you tell fans about this you  know it's  in canon it's about the guardians you're  gonna learn stuff that you need to learn  before you see volume three  and uh and it's great i'm really really  happy with it  are you gonna film that before you film  the movie i'm gonna film it at the same  time as a movie  you know i'm using a lot of the same  sets um  same actors obviously so we're filming  sort of  you know simultaneous with the film but  it's gonna have to be edited way sooner  because of  infinitely sooner because it's uh you  know  you know but it's not long it's not too  long it's a christmas special do you  envision this as being like a 30 minute  thing an hour is it a film  what is this oh it's like it's a short  it's it's not an hour it's definitely  not enough  it's under 40 minutes